evonik alter bitte 11 es ist eher so
schnell neue leute und herzlich
willkommen wenn ich mal wieder zu einer
weiteren folge des megaprojekts auf
eigentlich begrüßung machen
indem bilden ja indem building
na gut wir spielen es endlich mal wieder
eine neue runde
die tap projekt ist ok ganz viele
verschiedene modifikationen auf einem
server zusammen klatsch mit ganz vielen
anderen schwanz zu lutschen hier auf
einem server und da gebe jetzt direkt
drauf und schaut erst mal ob andere noch
drauf sind ja es sind chronik da
vielleicht habe ich mich dann gleich
einfach in die auf nachahmer hammer
hammer aber mama mama simon simari die
durchgezogene high level so ein bisschen
abchecken ob er wieder neue schilder
sind ich glaube nicht dass eine kiste
acht dass die von luk place place ja
nicht mehr mitspielt hatte jedem so ein
paar sachen gegeben dass wir auf jeden
fall net dankeschön dafür gleich sehr
sehr sozial
dass er dann natürlich auch an die
anderen denkt aber ich sehe erst mal
keine neuen stellen das sehr schön den
kopf nein
so machten plus richtig - majdic
f&e-projekte menge gemacht also ich war
zwei wochen auf dem server das ist
erstmal die sache denn wegen der da und
nicht was angebaut ist matthias park ist
jetzt auch wieder dabei und darf da
jetzt auch wieder weiter bauen hat sein
haus auch schon nahezu fertig kommen
muss vielleicht auch mal vorbeigucken
hätte auch schon sind komische wasser
allerdings kommt es grundstücks auch
sehr schön den abos sind kleine brücke
das typisch den einfach sagt die ads das
ist zenit der macht einfach gar nichts
lukaku oben allerdings gebaut erst sieht
man macht einfach nur des öko krams und
ich bin einfach noch mal jetzt auf
einmal wieder ganz hinten bei uns sind
übrigen grad arbeiter mautsystem
kanzlers ebenso drin das geräusch hört
ist dann kettensäge oder sowas keine
ahnung wer wir wieder abgeschlachtet
wird so mädels viele mich gefragt ich
lade erst mal kurz meine ach so erst mal
ganz kurz hier nachdem einigen vierteln
hier nachschauen was da so alles neue
ist nicht gut
turtle audis voll
hier sind auch noch ein paar sachen drin
von der turtle also wir werden jetzt
homo-ehe muss gleich noch mal was sagen
also ich hab ich eine menge sachen
anzuquatschen jetzt sei es erst mal die
ich hatte jetzt klausurphase bzw doch wo
ich grad aufnehme ist mittwoch schreibt
freitag noch sozialwissenschaften und
nächste woche mittwoch der mathematik
oder weil ich hab erst klose 3+
geschrieben da kann ich zweite mich
ruhig bisschen zurücklehnen und verdi
schmidt stefan block lernen und dann
jetzt so wie werde ich auf jeden fall
richtig viel lernen müssen allerdings
erstmals macht das alles morgen deswegen
die mich heute auf damit ihr wieder ein
paar folgen bekommt und dann kommt auch
die nächsten tage etwa einige meinten
dass sich dabei um gespielt oder so in
santa pod reingewinns love hat ihr das
hat keiner von denen gesagt dass ich
nicht gesagt ich habe tausend mal gesagt
schon vor 1000 folgen
ich habe das sogar gemacht als ich das
erste mal widmet mitkommen aufgenommen
hat habe ich gesagt wir wollten
eigentlich etwa heute aufnehmen
allerdings haben uns dann spontan für
epic job nicht entschieden dann hatte
der erste partner nehmen ein paar tagen
schon 100 100.000 aufrufe und alle
meinten so hey voll witzig mit euch dann
haben jetzt noch öfter epic games
gemacht
ihr könnt einfach mal daumen hoch gehen
oder halt in die kommentare schreiben ob
ihr noch die nächste epic auch mitkommen
wir sehen wollt weil die sets ist
gesetzt ob ich wieder rausgekommen oder
so die werden wir dann auch zusammen
über diese arbeit eine und gleich hoch
und klatschten mit penis links und
rechts sondern auch na ja ich habe mir
hier gerade gemacht eindringlich trat
ein bisschen nebenbei war ich noch nicht
mit mittagessen ab
einige wollen auch das mag auch videos
machen aber ich kann eigentlich gar
nicht kochen ich stelle mir das immer
alles macht man so ein foto das am ende
nein also bisschen kann ich schon aber
nicht so krass wird gibt's noch zu
erzählen also klausur in deutsch über
buddenbrocks ich natürlich also schreibt
man die kommentare ob ihr ob ihr wollt
das ist ein bisschen sogar mein leben
erzähle man leben was dann los mein
leben hat nicht gelernt nein bin total
hyperaktiv weil wir ganz der brause
gefressen haben in der school
deswegen bin ich gerade ein bisschen ads
also kann auch seine sprechweise bis
verändert hat weil ja kantersieg bis an
der brust liegt am kompletten lernen und
ich brauche eine auszeit und deswegen
nämlich jetzt auch auf skelette aber ihr
wisst ja ich bin ich selbst auf youtube
deshalb auch letztes mal welche
geschrieben dass ihr das so schätzt an
mir und ich möchte ich das auch nicht
verstellen und irgendwie jetzt hier den
typen machen der sitzung herzlich
willkommen zurück bei mega projekt ich
habe jetzt mal aus
das ist ja mehr also sparen sparen
sparen sparen
jetzt geht es halt so seine art meine
art ist er so ich mache das so wie ich
gerade bin
und ja also so gut er hat man hatte mir
eigentlich gegeben us silvers silber was
will ich damit silva leute das wollten
wir auch nochmal schreiben nicht
vergessen hier wollte eben auch
schreiben so schild habe ich immer noch
allem inventar elternrolle ich mich echt
ein nein also team das potenzial das
dann kann ich auch noch induction verein
tun wenn ich so dass jetzt ein tyrann in
der nachkriegs heraus
also gibt einfach ein daumen hoch wenn
ihr wollt dass ich mir sogar mein leben
quatsch das nicht gelernt und was alles
halt investoren also hier kommt kohl und
der ganz anderes darf rein die charts
bräuche zum zaubern wurde mir
geschrieben
rubin das ist geil ach so freunde hier
sprache ist deutsch er wieso ist eine
lobby egal ich bin gut drauf weil ich
jetzt halt zwei wochen ich aufgenommen
habe cool
er gibt mir baracke warum also danke
aber so brauch ich markt zum handeln
wollte ich auch noch aufladen an die
dann ist label dann kriegen wir keinen
strom mehr als organ sodann ich habe mir
hier rechts schon da auf dem desktop
ich habe hier rechts auf dem desktop ein
bild gemacht von meinem haus was ich mir
bauen wollte deswegen werde ich dann mal
ab und zu ein bisschen drauf wie die
schallplatte tierhalter bitte f dies ist
er so schnell macht jetzt diese schule
gemacht de besucht doch jetzt erstmal
was hast du die schuhe herz gefunden auf
otto.de
bei jungs penis energie back es geht
nichts crazy ob du deine schuhe was für
schuhe mit spannung wie bruce nauman so
schlecht rein gar nichts
entweder direkt über dem leute ja gleich
runter so fliegen wir mal wieder zurück
zu mir ich habe übrigens alle level
verloren ich gestorben bin aber da hat
er dabei ach nein stimmt das war ja oft
auf screen ach so ja wir hatten
unterhalten weil die ganzen schilder
geführt und sie darauf den schluss
gekommen dass das war allerdings
unbewusst weil da irgendwie werden den
pc war mit sache nicht mehr das war
jedenfalls gehweg hier weg von meinem
grundstück
trotzdem kann ich dich schlagen weil ich
skill hat die opfer
weg
beck
weg und zwar werde ich mein haus also ja
ich stand hier und dann haben wir das
ganze leid gesprochen ich dachte immer
wieder kam eine spende von hinten lane
bei spider und dann wurde ich halt von
der spinne getötet alle meine alten
schon ein bisschen weg und ich habe 30
level verloren sag mir deinen
schuhmodell es wird nacht schlafen
deswegen bin ich halt gestorben
allerdings wäre ich jetzt mein haus
bauen und was ich brauchte es auf jeden
fall kloster habe ich eigentlich klaus
daum als ich werde euch noch kein bild
zeigen ihr werdet dann nur halt das
endresultat den ich hätte doch bloß ton
gestorben da bin ich auf jeden fall noch
mal in den etat für gehen müssen gleich
beschädigte am bus schlafen also mein
haus fertig bauen und ich werde noch ein
paar industrial diamonds machen weil ich
ja jetzt so viel kohle habe dafür
übrigens keine kam am start waren
steffen mit main statt die von meiner
beiden sd-karten geht kennen was mit dem
kev
pf
wenn ich einfach denn gehen kann nicht
wahr
diese arbeiter ihr herz gehört es ist
unerträglich es ist unerträglich einfach
die schnauze warum sind die hier mein
gott oh mein gott ich werde jetzt erst
mal kannst jetzt erstmal wieder gas
geben
ich habe es zu viele pflastersteine ich
bräuchte gar nicht von new york aus und
das schlagzeug schlaf schlaf der euro
sorgt jedenfalls werde ich mich dann
heute erstmal ins haus kümmern und ein
bisschen um parade münster machen wollte
mir dann mfa machen und außerdem sind
die anderen jetzt wahrscheinlich weiter
als ich weil ich halt jetzt die letzten
drei vier tage kein mega programm ab und
holte sich aufgenommen habe aber das ist
mir relativ egal weil ich das halt nur
spiel wenn ich lust habe und damit auch
etwa mit comm.editsweb wahrscheinlich
kommt oder wieder mehr motto reviews und
mehr bvb den wegen blatt auch relativ
egal magath wird dann so nebenher
bisschen laufen wenn er dann ich wieder
so mehr motivation ab wie am anfang dann
wird dass sie richtig krass war dann
kommen wieder drei vier folgen täglich
habe jetzt erst mal weil ich die letzten
zwei tage nicht hochgeladen habe habe
ich jetzt erstmal mit jetzt los habe ich
die letzten tage habe ich jetzt die
nächsten tage auf jeden fall ist mal ein
kleines minimum budget was ich dann auf
brauchen darf sage ich mal
und ja das habe ich gar nichts geschafft
man jetzt pennt alter können jetzt immer
pennen gehn
es gibt international schulter
schillerjahr
jahrhundert
ja was sollte ich denn machen eine farm
bachhaus chains sorgen und die ganze
steine kann ich hier mal irgendwie weg
tun die ganzen in never muss ich auch
immer geben dann muss ich in durch sehr
netter portal gehen wenn ich das darf
sie fertig so und zwar luca was machst
du mit der james a ich werde zu machen
dass ich mein haus auf links setzte auf
diese links auf stelzen damit dass über
die ganzen anderen dingen sind wird ich
weiß noch nicht ich glaube ich setz da
so hin
aber ich bin mir noch nicht sicher ich
setze das hier so komplett drüber da
muss ich diesen baum genau da hinten
auch noch mal bauen deswegen brauche ich
jetzt das komische setzlinge hab ich die
dann noch eichenholz setzt legen 28 das
einer drin bleiben habe ich nicht habe
ich nicht jungs gibt mir setzen
ich hab ich keine pflege mehr das echt
traurig ja gut kann ich mich eigentlich
auch bei jahres geht auch schneller
angehen die blätter de weck ihr müsst
auf jeden fall erstmal weg die bäume die
hier sind bevor er zum 8 8 war nicht
alles kaputt erweitert ab freunde wartet
abu dhabi statt vergessen dass die
kerosin dran kann ja abbauen mensch
können die nicht die wehren von mal zu
mal lauter
da denk ich mir ja sie halten die
schnauze schön ruhig hatte die serie
vögel hören gleich allerdings kaum so
mies botton die zimtsterne erkennt dass
mit dem stempel der mann in die
kommentare schreiben
alter ads kinder hier
das ist normal ich weiß die müssen ihre
arbeit machen und so das ist auch noch
spaß von mir aber trotzdem